fallout 4 has a ton of DLC on the way
but it's not the only post-apocalyptic
game getting new content fallout shelter
is getting a massive update this week
packed with new features new pets and
new rooms it's the game's biggest update
yet first and foremost we're getting
crafting if you liked modding your gear
and fallout 4 you'll love jerry-rigging
items together on your smartphone along
with this comes new armor and weapon
workshops barbershops are also coming to
the vaults and you'll be able to
customize the look of every vault
dweller with new weapons and outfits
animal lovers will also be happy to know
that new dogs and cats are also on their
way Plus parrots changes to time of day
and lunch box cards are also included in
the update Bethesda is certainly giving
fallout shelter the support it deserves
and considering it made over 5 million
dollars in its first week you can't
blame them and it won't be the last
update either whenever Bethesda
announces more you'll hear all about it
from your pals at gamespot